all right well back from Justice League
and I'm just gonna come right out the
gate here and maybe start with my bottom
line the bottom line I did not hate it
it's not good it's not good it's not
good but I didn't hate it I feel like
that's a good starting point I I'm
expecting that audiences are actually
going to be very soft on the movie that
they're gonna be willing to forgive it a
lot specifically because the the final
20 minutes of the movie are actually
pretty entertaining otherwise otherwise
it's it's a mess and it does not start
out on its on its best foot the first
shot of the movie you may have heard
okay you may have heard that during
reshoots
henry cavill had facial hair he had had
a mustache that he he grew for another
movie for another role that he was in
and he was contractually prevented from
shaving it and Warner Brothers was not
able to negotiate between all of the
different producers and so they did the
reshoots with the mustache and removed
it digitally in post and boy does it
show and the first shot of the movie
which is simulated iPhone footage is one
of these shots and it is not good so
what what you this this actually kind of
helps me on on my end because it becomes
it's so obvious the parts where the
parts where they have removed the
mustache are so obvious that it becomes
a really easy marker of like okay what
did they go in and do reshoots of when
Whedon was brought on board and it's a
lot now the final edit of a movie is
always going to biased or
it's the reshoots for kind of obvious
reasons that is like alright well they
went back specifically to get that
footage so that footage is more likely
to end up in the finished movie in the
in the final cut and in this case like
you're looking I I would need to go
through and like actually count it but
it is substantial the finished cut is
somewhere between 25 maybe even as high
as 50 percent depending on what
sequences were originally intended to be
included but it's it's substantial at
least a quarter of the movie that you
will see on screen is is from Whedon's
reshoots and gauging that is is easy
thanks to thanks to Henry cowls truly
truly uncanny likeness he appears in
this movie almost entirely as CGI a lot
of body double replacement obviously a
lot of face replacement it's it's very
unsettling and it indicates a huge
course correction in terms of where
where they decided to go with the movie
midstream and in production I
I would be fascinated to see the Zack
Snyder version because this is
definitely this is definitely not in
like even if he has expressed his
approval of it like this is not his
movie at well it's half his movie the
first half is definitely his movie the
the most straightforward comparison to
kind of make actually is is Suicide
Squad it has a lot of the same issues as
or no I shouldn't say it has the same
issues the because
it's actually not it's the opposite of
that it doesn't have the same issues it
has the same density of problems as
Suicide Squad but in completely
different ways in fact of of the movies
that have had just kind of like this
this baffling sort of editing that I've
seen so if you're talking Suicide Squad
the Snowman and now now Justice League
like all three of them are actually very
distinct in terms of like what their
actual problems are so where Suicide
Squad they went in and they took a like
three four-hour movie and didn't just
try to compress it into into a
digestible package into a two-hour movie
they they also you know they had all the
competing edits and they got really
funky with trying to to spice up the
formula as they were doing it so you end
up with with really really jarring
incomprehensible sort of editing in
large chunks of it because they're
moving so much around like they're
actually restructuring much of the early
plot of the film in order to try and
make it work in a new stylized package
this one is similar probable starting
problem in that they had a movie that
was way too long
but even after the reshoots like they
still so they went and Whedon when did
the reshoots and then in August they had
a more or less three-hour cut that they
were that they were test screening and
they were telling exhibitors basically
to expect a you know three hour movie
and then the one that gets to theaters
is you know two hours and so a an almost
an hour like 50 55 minutes disappeared
and it shows but rather than
reorganizing and restructuring it they
just they say
a they sent an editor into the booth to
be just absolutely ruthless and just
told them like no mercy get it down to
you know get it down to two hours and
and you have two weeks to do it and
whoever it was went in and was ruthless
and just cut out like they didn't try
they didn't get fancy they didn't they
didn't try to like spice it up they just
cut out every establishing shot every
brooding moment every ounce of padding
everything that wasn't vital to the plot
or a joke and jokes brings me to sort of
the next thing to talk about which is
tone there's a distinct tone problem in
the movie cut the the two directors have
very much left their own voice in the
film you can distinctly tell the stuff
that is Snider's because it looks and
feels like
Snyder's stuff it looks and feels like
the previous two movies the Whedon stuff
doesn't and the Whedon decision-making
in the cut shows and whether or not this
is actually like Whedon Whedon or if
this was corporate mandate from Warner
Brothers who knows but they have in the
cut decided to leave in what feels like
every single Barry Allen snide remark
whether or not they should have whether
or not it actually belonged if you've
seen the trailers there's a joke that
they put in the trailers as they put
rather prominent in the trailers where
Barry basically pulls Batman aside and
they have
back and forth about like oh man like
it's great that you guys look like
you're ready to go into like go and do
battle but I've never done battle before
I've just pushed people and run away and
it's like you know hey you want to keep
that it's kind of a funny line however
however that line that gag is inserted
like it is sandwiched between between
moments of Steppenwolf just executing
people like and I'm not talking like you
know comic book movie executions I'm
talking like bone cracking you know
gurgle deaths even if they're happening
off screen though even the fact that
they are happening off screen is is
somewhat more sinister because like the
sounds the sounds that telegraph these
off-screen deaths are gross not
inappropriate just gross like the kind
of tonal found and environment building
that you have come to expect from these
Schneider Superman movies and so to go
from like Steppenwolf basically ripping
a person's head off - Barry Allen joke
and joking about how he's not ready to
do battle back to Steppenwolf like
killing someone like breaking their back
and throwing them into a wall is mm not
great flow like maybe pick one tone or
the other and then the the climax of the
movie has a completely different tone
than everything else and to its benefit
the the dialogue doesn't get Whedon
esque ever really I mean aside from how
Barry's kind of always in there but it's
not it's it's not a problem if
not it overall it's not not really there
but the Whedon understands why people
like Superman and Whedon has and you can
tell because they're reshoots because of
the mustache removal Whedon has made
Superman into kind of the Superman that
everybody sort of wanted / expected all
along and so it's a lot you know the the
climax is a lot more lighthearted it's a
lot more adventuresome it's a lot more
friendly it's less oppressive a tone
people are happy like they're making
jokes because they're having fun not
because it's like gallows humor it's
very weird like aunt even the parts that
aren't like the that aren't super
obvious mustache removal it's still very
kind of uncanny watching Henry Cavill
Superman smile like it's it's its own
kind of unsettling because it's like
because they've given him just this
resting sneer for two movies now and
I've spent so much time with that sneer
that watching him smile is a little it's
a little unsettling and a weird kind of
thing that they did with this movie is
their sort of whole approach to dealing
with Batman vs Superman is just to
ignore the parts of the everything about
Batman vs Superman that they just don't
want to deal with which would not
normally be a problem except for how
intrinsically tied to Batman vs.
Superman it is like literally everything
about the plot like this movie does not
make a lick of sense if you haven't seen
Batman vs Superman
it is a hard sequel
and so in that regard it's it's very
weird to have everyone kind of behaving
as though events in Batman versus
Superman were went differently one of
the main things is that the the whole
like first act like prologue into first
act of this movie is predicated on the
explicit declaration that since
Superman's death things have gotten
worse but there-there is tied to that
and this comes in heavily during the the
intro credits sequence which is a very
very Zack Snyder introduction like if
you you will have Watchmen flashbacks if
if you watch it and the storytelling in
that sequence implies that all of these
things from war and poverty and whatnot
are escalating dramatically as a direct
consequence of the death of Superman
that's what it says using cinematic
language and also regular language
because people in slightly different
words say exactly that the the problem
there is that the the world-building
assumption of Batman vs Superman
completely disagrees with that
assessment because the world-building
assumption of Batman vs Superman is that
the world was a crap hole and Superman
could do nothing to stem the tide of it
like that is that is core to the
identity of Batman vs Superman is
revolving around this whole hand
wringing over like Superman actually
make
the world worse by doing stuff like that
he wasn't making the world better and
the things that he was doing weren't
fixing anything substantial and you know
it he wasn't giving people hope not on
mass like he they kept saying this I go
well he's inspiring people but by and
large the world units in in the sense of
the world was you know cynical and
decaying and unworthy of Superman
you know white Perry White has a whole
diatribe in in Batman vs Superman about
how the world like you know America's
conscience died with Jack Robert and and
Martin you know that I just had somebody
in my mentions a couple days ago arguing
that the the central premise of Batman
vs Superman is that you know the world
was too cynical for him the world didn't
deserve Superman and I mean that doesn't
work in the face of the fact that you
know Superman in that movie is an
but anyway like the they do a
very thorough job of establishing in BVS
that the world sucks and things are bad
and no matter what Batman no matter what
Superman does nothing seems to actually
get better and so to go from that to oh
man things are you know basically things
were roses back when Superman was alive
but now everything's fallen
part is is kind of weird and and more
than a little more than a little strange
I I suppose maybe you could view it as a
bit of a spoiler ish that Superman's
endless a lot but it's hard to avoid
because he's actually in this movie a
lot like the the trailer is kind of
waffled back and forth between
pretending that he was going to stay
dead and just did knowledge and
yeah he's back and he cuz he comes back
he actually they they resurrect him
about halfway through the movie in a
sequence that is completely devoid of
tension because they need to move the
plot along they've got okay this is
actually the segment the middle segment
of this movie is actually where the
editing is is worst so the the league
gets together and and they decide they
have they have a showdown with
Steppenwolf so Steppenwolf let's let's
do a little bit of a plot plot rundown
Steppenwolf wants three MacGuffins he he
takes one from the Amazons he takes one
from the Atlanteans and then he's
looking for the third and the league has
a short little showdown with him and
they managed to kinda kind of kind of
get him to scram he takes off and they
go and grab the third MacGuffin and hold
on to it and decide to use it to
resurrect Superman and the time between
deciding to resurrect him or to use the
MacGuffin to to cure death and
Superman being just live again is about
five minutes maybe ten it goes very
quickly with zero complications more or
less and and is a very silly sequence
but not in a intended silly way it's
just it's silly because it moves way too
fast and then he the the big the the
patchy Estanza popping in this where so
Superman comes back alive and MacGuffin
goes flying into the air and then they
show it landing on top of a cop car it's
a it's a mother box by the way they show
they show the mother box landing on top
of a cop car and then everybody ignores
it despite the fact they know they team
knows explicitly that if Steppenwolf
gets his hands on this third mother box
he will be able to destroy the world and
they know he has to they know he has to
they've got the third they cannot let
him get it it lands on this cop car and
they just leave it there they just
ignore him there's you know flash Wonder
Woman cyborg Aquaman Batman five they
got five of them five people and all
five people go and and just have this
confrontation with Superman okay fine
with this so far then in a hilarious
moment they see Steppenwolf's like
stargates pillar thing open his portal
opens they cut away to the mother box
lying on top of this cop car back to the
heroes and the heroes are like oh crap
the mother box we got to go get it and
then the portal just closes and it's
like oh I guess Steppenwolf has it now
we screwed up
dang it's it's it's pretty funny you
don't even see you don't even see
Steppenwolf in that segment so that is
probably the Claudius editing moment
where like I don't know what originally
happened there everything in not quite
everything a huge huge portion of of
that sequence is clearly reshoots so
potentially all of it is reshoots so who
knows what that's papering over you know
who knows what was originally supposed
to happen in in that chunk of the movie
to get from here to there and the
Superman reshoots are so pervasive there
are so many of them
the they're obvious that I'm actually
kind of wondering if they if Superman
was ever really in the movie sort of the
the reason I say that like clearly he
was gonna always come back but when and
how seems to have been completely redone
during the Whedon stuff because huge
chunks of the climax are clearly Whedon
the resurrection of Superman sequence is
clearly Whedon it's it's so substantive
in terms of the the importance within
the structure of the movie
that it doesn't just feel like oh we
needed to kind of fix some shots we
needed to smooth over some dialogue we
needed to maybe you know punch it up a
bit it feels it goes to the level of
like this was probably completely
different
at one point also during the sequence
where they do the resurrection the
mother box looks completely different
than it does at every other time in the
movie so there's a a not unlikely
there's a not unlikely chance that
resurrecting Superman may have once been
much much much later in the film and did
not require the mother box at all and
that that was reworked and that there
was originally a completely different
way that Steppenwolf got ahold of the
third one I don't know it's really
confusing and the middle the middle
chunk of this movie is what I think a
lot of people are going to end up sort
of fixating on because it's it's a mess
but then then yeah they finally they go
and actually no before that so there's
there's a really funny kind of side
conversation so during during the like
five minutes that they're debating
whether or not they should resurrect
Superman one of the one of the
complaints that's brought up or one of
the one of the the philosophical
questions that his poise is posed is you
lose something in dying and you know
you're dying changes your like your
personality and in this case it
absolutely 100% does because it turns
out that dying made Superman into less
of a prick he he smiles now he
jokes he has a sense of humor he looks
like someone who knows what fun is he's
played completely different completely
different in in in his post-death stuff
at least after after he kind of snaps
back to accepting that he's he's back
alive which which goes pretty quickly it
goes by fast enough that characters
actually like comment on how quickly he
came to terms with you know not being
dead anymore so yeah then the last 20
minutes are big long action sequence a
lot of it sucks and is very boring
action sequence but the actual fight
against Steppenwolf particularly once
once Superman shows up it's actually got
some it's got some character to it
it's fun it's dynamic there's actually
stuff that happens it gets very comic
book II in a good way finally and leaves
you kind of wishing that like oh if only
we had had this Superman for two movies
already instead of a quarter of a movie
yeah and I'm trying to think of other
major things that really kind of stood
out to me there's a lot of teleporting
in the movie I mean this isn't this
isn't a huge problem per se like it's I
don't know it's it's one of those
there's one of those sticking points
where it's like they get a little too
loose with the with the time frame at
times particularly like character
movement like people will just pop back
and forth from from metropolis to Kansas
and back like instantaneously
you know in a very
weird way and now when it's the
superheroes doing it you're liking
whatever they're superheroes but there's
there's a point where ma can't does it
as well like she's explicitly in
Metropolis and then like right away
she's in Kansas again and it's like okay
that's just kind of that's just kind of
sloppy also there's a scene near the
beginning where it's a very it's very
clearly a Zack Snyder scene where Lois
has to talk for an extended period of
time and it leaves you painfully aware
that Zack Snyder has never once bothered
to sit down and actually develop this
character and her voice and it's awful
it's it is it is truly truly abysmal
dialogue and and yeah yeah so a weird
mix of of fun Silver Age superhero
action and modern Snyder grimness but
like I said back at the beginning like I
think I think audiences are gonna give
it a lot of leeway just because the
ending is is pretty fun and personally I
I don't I don't hate it
I enjoyed parts of it it didn't leave a
sour taste in my mouth because it's not
it's not a misanthropic cesspit so just
just the simple fact that it seems to
have found a modicum of joy makes it a
lot more bearable despite its its
numerous numerous flaws and yeah so
probably don't go see it because it's
still bad but if you do go see it you
you won't it shouldn't leave you in pain
and hating the world so there's that